io non so che cosa cazzo sono questi ma
sono veramente pdl a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono fa
vj detto oggi siamo in un nuovo blog
come al solito direi di cominciare con
la parte della settimana che questa
settimana è stata vinta da the choice
che ho fatto questo splendido fare altra
ghazi sul già messo dentro tutti cazzo
di oggetti che ho ricevuto negli ultimi
blocchi e fantastica e direi che
possiamo passare le news ragazzi perché
devo dirgli delle cose forse queste
saranno le news più belle che dirò mai
in un blog in vita mia per prima cosa
ragazzi volevo ringraziarvi di cuore per
il traguardo strepitoso di 700mila
iscritti ragazzo non troppi troppi non
pensava veramente di raggiungerla
penocchio storico sempre ormai sono
scontato come come il pelo sul kiwi
giuro che non era venuto un cazzo di
paragone migliore di lei ragazzi che con
le news possa farvi un regalo cioè sia
degno di tutto questo allora per prima
cosa ragazzi sono contentissimo che
outlast vi stia piacendo come seria
anche perché mi costa qualche anno di
vita a registrarla che lo sa che è stato
aspettando un secondo episodio mai se
fosse una manna dal cielo ma state
tranquilli della prossima settimana lo
faccia uscire il prima possibile
comunque ragazzi la news pazzesca che è
veramente non potevo crederci nemmeno io
quando l'ho saputo è da almeno un anno
che io vi prometto che quando ci danno o
tipo e monde sleeping verbis virtus che
sono due giochi che avete apprezzato
tantissimo e anche tre doubt è la cosa
che non ci potevo credere nemmeno io è
che tutti e tre questi titoli escono
tutti quanti a metà di maggio è pazzesco
un che ragazzi come trade auto e damon
che slip sono due horror credo che li
farò quando quando finirò di fare
outlast perché faccio una serie oro alla
volta ma che sono tutti insieme sono si
capisce più un cazzo
mentre per quanto riguarda in verbis
virtus ragazzi quello che dovete fare le
magie a voce quello credo di farlo
subito perché non è un horror quindi è
una è una serie che iniziano subito
evento questo ragazzi ho finito con le
news spero siete contenti anche perché
sono cose che mi chiedevate dall'altro
secolo è detto questo ragazzine che
possiamo passare allo scartarlo dei
pacchi
legami che cazzo vediamo se riesco a una
mazzata
ecco non ma perché uno deve cadere
sempre se non c'è verso praticamente
sono quattro tra cui questo che c'è una
chan ha scritto della madonna cena e
[ __ ] chiede ai ragazzi di partire
dal più piccolo chiesti cazzi non è più
quello per niente mica giacché si scatta
facilmente è una gioia mi avete inviato
delle scarpe e comunque ragazzi anche se
infatti si scartano per voi non la carta
che palle no vabbè vabbè che questo
questo è bellissimo è una cosa è una
cosa dolci notissima tipo che sto
vomitando zucchero era casa morbidosi
ssimo che mai ragazzi sostituisce una
tetta perché morbidoso al punto giusto
che ti voglio bene anch'io chiunque tu
sia ragazzi ve lo voglio dedicare a voi
visto che siamo legati a 700mila
controllato splendido e questo cuore
ragazzi lo voglio dedicare ad ognuno di
voi
[Musica]
ti stai commuovendo c'è poi ragazzi sono
ancora in cucina con fra cat mario cos'è
stato ragazzi altro che è che benedetta
parodi quali abbiamo chiesto mario che
cucina meglio di chiunque altro
ok passiamo al prossimo con rabbia
perchè non vedo di aprirlo anche perché
a me con curiosissimo resto già col
disegno davanti hai vinto tutto ragazzi
ci siamo un altro scrigno sta per essere
aperto ci vorrebbero così che sta tipo
quella di zelo
[Musica]
sembra questo questo me lo metto sul
comodino alla lotta e non dormo più ve
lo dico comunque grazie mille ragazzi
c'è una pro sesto un cucchiaio con una
faccia ma che se perché chiudere ragazzi
si sono 12 miliardi di fan art splendide
tra l'altro sono bellissime e grazie di
tre sono le copertine dei video che
avevo fatto cioè la ri fatte a mano una
cosa splendida grazie mille e come
ultimo ragazzi direi che posso prendere
godzilla qui perché mi starà mi sta
chiamando da mezz'ora perché non lo so
credo che mi occupi una stanza intera di
casa mia alla ragazzina prima grossa e
per questo c'è una banana bara con
scrittori pfa vige youtuber amato la mia
data di nascita e la data di morte che
che non è ancora stata scritta
la sostituirò che la mia vera data di
morte quando succederà anche mangia
nostro fa nutella grazie mille cose non
ci risparmia sopra questa maglietta l'ha
disegnata dipinta io spero si abitua
gradimento e di vedersela saprà durante
qualche torbido bella fare i pang e lo
succhia quanto spazio ragazzi e più
vivere nei mie normali non ci posso
credere ci ha dato ci sono tutti quelli
su motori che mario c'è anche mia nonna
probabilmente da qualche parte che non
la vedo così scrive e splendida non c'è
non ci sono parole grazie di cuore è
potevano mancare la nutella sul braccio
che mi riguarda quanto mi fa maggio che
dire grazie mille mie mi sa che ci hai
un futuro la stilista al posto di armani
dopo dichiara grazie una fa cup dio nord
questa festa questa è la fan art più
fottutamente bella che io abbia mai
visto
cioè ci sono io che squarto che mario
con la mano questo è amore e poi ragazzi
c'è ancora un ulteriore paccone ce ne
sono un miliardo è già scritta della
roba sopra ragazzi che ciò veramente
paura ad aprirlo questo ve lo dico per
ragazzi sica bene aperti già un casino e
so che qua dentro ci sarà qualcosa di
epico
direi che possa aprire nel prossimo blog
perché ne ho aperti già un miliardo
sorpassano blog alla prima pacchi così
vi lascio anche in suspense
congregazioni cavato una maglietta
spettacolare un cucchiaio bellissimo e
anche un ricettario per far cucina
sono ragazzi continuerà lo scarta cio
che ho iniziato nel prossimo blog di lei
di passare al family sponde la prima
domanda ragazzi arriva da valentina che
scrive poi risponde perché lo sai perché
tutte le ragazze ti amano compresa me la
risposta è semplicissima valentina
perché ci avete bisogno di un bel paio
d'occhiali e io so anche quali ciao pamy
tradizione che hai fatto qual è stata la
tua preferita se un grande allora in
realtà la mia serie preferita io direi
autras fra tutte sono contentissimo che
sia il sito dlc a parte per gli infarti
poi risponde cosa fa federica pellegrini
quando non nuota allora se non nuota ed
è in acqua sono un po cazzi quando è
fuori dall'acqua saranno fatti suoi
credo che mi risponde favino perché la
tua età non hai la barba perché io in
realtà sono un pesce
va bè ragazzi prima di concludere dvd
passare alla fabi domanda perché in
realtà voglio termine delle domande che
mi avete fatto per il prossimo blog
perché per la prossima volta voglio fare
un qualcosa di un po più speciale che
sto organizzando e quindi voglio tenere
per il prossimo blog scusate se ho
risposto a poche domande stavolta ma
vedrete del prossimo e come fai domande
ragazzi vi voglio chiedere qual è il
personaggio che mette preferito durante
i miei gameplay ne sono un miliardo tipo
jack sparso pif mario che spero non
scegliate ma e quindi ragazzi dire che
posso concludere qui per oggi come al
solito se il video è piaciuto nel sotto
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come univideo tratta nella
descrizione sete prestiti iscrivetevi ci
vediamo la prossima vivo ma l'avevo
detto no chemical aveva il telecomando
quando siete presidi scrivetemi ci
vediamo prossimo video ragazzi